hello everyone and welcome to the new
good stuff
it's the Paul Morphy saga the pride and
sorrow of chess as the title says now
why is a Paul Morphy now referred to as
the pride and sorrow of chess well
that's what we are about to discover on
this Paul Morphy journey and for the for
the first video and for the first game
in this video series I decided to show
you a nice game where morphe was eight
and a half maybe nine years old and he's
playing against his father alonso
michael morphe it's a really short fun
game that shows how how how morphe
understood chess from a very young age
but before we actually check out the
game we should talk a bit more about how
everything started and how how their
family got to New Orleans in Louisiana
and well one of the things that might
come to you is a surprise why is the
portrait of Paul Murphy's father in
color whereas portrait of Paul Morphy is
in black and white how is this even
possible
well Paul Murphy's father Alonso Michael
Murphy was a pretty big deal in in
Louisiana and that's why he has a photo
in color it's actually still hanging in
in their house today in New Orleans so
if you are passing by you can check it
out
but we're gonna get back to that so how
everything started well for a lot of you
may not know that but along the Michael
Murphy was of Spanish nationality but he
also was of Portuguese Spanish and Irish
heritage point being that Michael Murphy
Paul Murphy's great grandfather moved
from Ireland to Madrid in Spain in 1753
and as it was customary there to
pronounce it differently he changed his
name from Michael Murphy to Michael
Murphy so those of you who are perhaps
from Ireland you know the better check
twice maybe maybe you are just you know
carrying that genius Murphy gene in you
and you know you just might have a
little more feet running around in your
house so yeah check for that but yeah he
he came from Ireland to Madrid in Spain
in 1753 and as France colonized
Louisiana up until 1763 after
a seven-year war where Spain took
Louisiana from France and it was not
until 1802 when Napoleon wanted back
from Spain but it was a problematic
keeping it so France decided that it
would be better just to get rid of it
and it was President Thomas Jefferson
who actually bought a Louisiana from
from France for fifteen million dollars
if you take inflation into consideration
I I did some online inflation
calculation and it turns out that
fifteen fifteen million dollars in in
1803 would be something like two hundred
and fifty five million dollars today but
that's not the actual amount that it
cost the United States to buy Louisiana
from France the the total amount would
would be like 2.7 billion dollars
because that was only for the purchase
from France but of course there were a
lot of a lot of native native Native
American tribes living there and well of
course they had to reimburse all of them
and a lot of them were relocated
forcefully and in the end the the cost
of acquiring it to this day is like 2.7
billion dollars that's the official
official amount but a point being
Michael Murphy Michael Murphy originally
had a son Don Diego Murphy who was a
Paul Murphy's grandfather and he was
appointed consulship at the Port of New
Orleans so that's one of the reasons
Thomas Jefferson decided it was
extremely important to buy Louisiana and
not because of just the size but because
of the Mississippi port in New Orleans
and this is where Murphy's grandfather
is appointed consulship
and where he will move his family in
1809 some twenty eight years before
before Paul Murphy is even born and Don
Diego Murphy had two sons the gentleman
here as you can see about the board
Alonso Michael Murphy and Ernest Murphy
Murphy's uncle who will also be playing
a lot of games against Paul Murphy and
he will have a lot of influence on
Murphy when he is you know deciding
where of the places were not to play
chess because
just this entire saga it's it's hard to
really grasp everything more fees
decision whether to play or not to play
chess as he was constantly struggling
with this more fees thoughts about the
civil war more fees well
expectations of more fees members of the
Murphy family towards Paul Morphy as all
of them were really high achieving
individuals so it really wasn't easy for
Paul even though he was extremely
talented at a lot of things not to just
chess so his father Alonso Michael
Murphy he was Attorney General of the
Louisiana state and later he was
appointed the the Justice of the Supreme
Court of Louisiana so that's why we do
have a portrait in color of him he was a
very big deal and nautical a color
portrait of Paul Murphy and also his
wife along his wife Louise was a very
talented musician she played the harp
and the the piano a Louise of the of the
prominent French Creole II family so
like I said all of the members of the
Murphy family were high achieving
individuals and this put a lot of a lot
of strain on Murphy you know regarding
what he should you know achieve in life
and such soon yeah like I said this is
one of the games I decided to show you
the start of the saga Paul Murphy versus
his father I don't have a photo of a
young morph even though Murphy's like
eight and a half nine years old here I
did use some image software to try and
make him a little bit younger but in the
end I I think it just thinned thinned
out his face so you know there's just
that but yeah also there's like a very
interesting story about when Paul Murphy
was was very young about this age maybe
a bit younger than this because his
father and his uncle Ernest didn't know
that Murphy could play chess but he was
watching his father and his uncle play
chess and the game ended in a draw his
father and his uncle agreed to a draw
and Morphy said it's not a draw you
could have won that game and his father
asked him how how could I wanted to have
won that game and Murphy put the pieces
back together there
where's where they were in the endgame
and he showed a rough sacrifice after
which a checkmate fault so both of them
were very impressed and they didn't know
how a little little pole would know such
things but that's the that's the way the
story goes now there are similar stories
about Capablanca but which is not
surprising as both both of them were
well genius is at a very young age and
also there's the story or well it's not
actually a story there are also
published articles about this that
Winfield Scott American general and
chess player visited the Murphy family
and they invited him over to play a
chess game against a very strong chess
player he thought he would go and face
either Ernest Murphy who was a renowned
chess player in New Orleans but in the
end they put the the 10 year-old Paul
Morphy in front of him which he thought
he was 10 but more he was actually
younger and there is no well there is no
PGN of these games there are no moves
but it is said that Murphy won the first
game in 10 moves like the second game in
maybe even less and it was just well
that was the first time people saw that
more if he could actually play chess now
we don't have moves of those games but I
decided to show this one it's from 1847
he played against his father and he was
about the same age so just to show you
what we're dealing with here although I
think morphus father was a bit stronger
player than and in General Winfield
Scott so that being said let's check out
this very nice game and kick off the
saga so what did morphe play he had the
white pieces he opened with e4 of course
his father replied with E 5 and here we
have f4 Morphy goes for the King's
gambit and in those days of course every
gambit was accepted so e captures on f4
and now Bishop to c4 the bishops gambit
inviting Queen to h4 check now this is
something morphe did not study although
at this day this is this is considered
okay for whites to play so Queen to h4
check and now King the f1 and now if
this was a modern game we would see
something like Knight to f6
v6 even a counter blow with the d5 but
it's not it's a game from 1847 so Bishop
to c5 by morph is far already
threatening checkmate on an f2 now today
such a move wouldn't really be
considered because you can just block it
with d4 this is exactly what morphe does
but keep in mind that morphe is very
very young here so Bishop to b6 and now
Knight to f3 and this is kind of the
point of this opening of the
disabilities gambit in the Kings gambit
accepted now you you kick away the black
Queen and you start rapidly developing
pieces which is what Paul Morphy is
basically all about rapid development
and you know helping your pieces so they
can help you so Queen back to e7 and now
Knight to c3
so already you can see that the knight
the bishop this Knight Paul Morphy
already has a very nice Center but he
stays his king is stuck on f1 he has
some problems bringing the rook into the
game but this is not considered that is
considered better for white so Knight to
f6 we're now preparing to Castle and
here although II 5 would be played
pretty much automatically in modern
chess more if he continues with Queen to
d3 we have c6 now preparing d5 and
Bishop characters on f4 just recapturing
the pawn with d5 now striking in the
center which shows that morphus father
is also quite the player he's not afraid
to counter counter attack he captures on
d5 and now you don't want to allow rook
to e1 well the Queen and King are still
occupying the same file so just castles
we have d6 by Murphy now advancing that
pawn creating a very strong past pawn
and the Queen to d8 and here rook to e1
again just the rapid rapid development
this is what what this is what Paul
Morphy chess is all about with rook to
e8 and now Knight to g5 putting pressure
on h7 and also as Josh Waitzkin would
say you know check for the space left
behind so the f7 pawn is due to rook e8
the f7 pawn is now not protected so also
there's the threat of just capturing
that bone so first Alonso goes rook
captures anyone with King captures
anyone
and now queen ta twit check we have King
2d - and now comes Bishop to e6
countering this Bishop but already here
you can see that it's going to be a
problem for black to keep this structure
because now more if he brings the other
look into the game rook to e1 now
putting pressure on the bishop here and
it's not possible to defend it you do
you cannot bring a second defender to
the bishop and also blocking with Knight
here just allows the immediate mate
Queen h7 King f8 and Quint h8 mate
because the pawn covers the e7 square so
Knight B to d7 and now comes Knight
captures on e6 pretty pretty
straightforward F captures on e6 and now
rook captures an e6 and it was in this
position unmoved 18 that morph is father
Alonso Michael Murphy resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so what if you resign well whatever you
do if you move the Queen if you don't
want to look in let's say Queen FA just
let's say rook captures and f6 opens up
and it's a discovery wins the Queen just
the same and if you bring the Queen
somewhere else let's say Queen da then
it's just mate in one since it's it's a
double attack and in case of a double
check
you can only escape double check by
moving the King and since the King has
no squares of course this is a beautiful
checkmate so yeah that's the first game
I decided to show in the saga Paul
Morphy at the age I don't know about
eight and eight and a half
18:47 so yeah although yeah nine and a
half
it would seem yeah it was born in 37
this is in 47 yeah at 10 or or maybe
nine and a half but still it was
sometimes after the story told and after
the visit of the American general but
yeah you can see already at a very young
age he was he was able to play chess in
a different matter he understood that
rapid development is to keep the success
so something to you know modern engines
do you know without a problem and even
though today at the age of 10 of course
you have the key kids at the age of 10
are monsters today you know with which
memory
engine lines and with a much better
understanding of chess in those days in
1847 that was not the case and this was
this was considered well just incredible
and although okay along to Michael
Murphy Paul's father wasn't a great
chess player but he was decent he's his
brother Ernest was it was a much better
player but Murphy also destroyed him
already from a very young age he's even
able to beat him in blindfold chess it
already at the age of 11 but for for our
next videos I think we're already gonna
gonna go forward to the visit of
Hungarian and master Leventhal and he's
for Murphy's first encounter with our
renowned chess master so that's a little
bit what I want to say like I said it's
hard to grasp really everything I wanted
to capture in the Morphy saga but you
know it one day if I really become big
channel if I will be able to afford it I
you know I hope we can do like like a
Netflix series on Paul Morphy so where
we could just you know ill you know show
everything that so people can appreciate
it but yeah I will put some of the links
I've used in my research for for the
morphe saga some books some vlogs some
some websites so do check that out it
will be all in the description below if
you want to further your knowledge so
something will be covering of course
Murphy's childhood we will talk a bit
more about that in the videos to follow
the first American chest congress murphy
going there that challenge to Howard
Stanton why it did or may have not
happened his trip to England his trip to
France and we're gonna cover of course
he's a legendary encounter with Adolf
Anderson it's just the the clash of the
clash of titans and of course Murphy's
retirement and and what happened after
that so and I'm not gonna spoil anything
now but you know yeah you know stay
tuned for more of the good stuff so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
as it is the start of our brand new saga
are you awarded for it so I do hope you
will enjoy it I would like to thank
Frank Holmes
Michael Kovalchuk Joe Wilkinson Michael
quiz and then John Sandford
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
Steel continuing the Women's World Chess
Championship and of course continuing
now the brand new Paul Morphy saga so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day